russell kane he's known as a
multi-award-winning comedian
presenter actor author and scriptwriter
but man
this guy is so much more i started doing
all this biohacking and to
survive on less sleep to not lose your
hair or
to slow down the aging process
it [ __ ] my life in the proper sense
everything fell apart
like a junkie how can i get more of that
my relationship with my girlfriend fell
apart
my bill started to not be paid i started
to look thin
it's the closest thing to a drug
addiction i've ever experienced
[Music]
russell kane he's known as a
multi-award-winning comedian
presenter actor author and scriptwriter
but man this guy is so much more he's
genuinely deeply intellectually curious
something that honestly surprised me
and this sounds like it might be a
offensive or a weird thing to say but
i'm going to say it anyway
i didn't realize how smart this guy is
remarkably self-aware and on to top it
all off
brutally honest he says that how it is
he has an ability to point out things
that i think most of us muggles miss
and he's also genuinely just a really
nice and hilarious human being
today you won't hear many jokes this is
the more serious side of russell cain
and a side of him that i did not know
and would not have guessed
before speaking to him so without
further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
russell hello one of the things i read
when i was um reading about your story
was a quote um and i'm gonna read the
quote to you
you said i remained a boy while he was
alive
even when i was 18 and i needed to be a
man to tell these stories
what were you talking about when you
said that um well i don't think that's
true of just me i think any
boy or probably girl who has a
reasonably overbearing and dominant
father you sort of remain
a child now that i'm a father myself i
can see that's true so when my daughter
mina is
40 she's still gonna be my my baby so
that's the positive side of it
the negative side of it is if it's quite
an overbearing masculine
energy you saw i felt sometimes a bit
like a bonsai like i kept nearly growing
and then the roots were trimmed so i was
fully grown but small
so if my dad was in the room you know i
was instantly
a child like i would say inside so it's
just a very dominating figure and i
think that would have been the same
had my dad not dropped down dead from a
heart attack years ago
i think that would have been the same
when i'd been 40 50 60 if my dad had
been
90 year old shouting in the corner
probably still would have been like that
even if he wasn't in the room
no no when as soon as what in his
presence i think but so far as this
that i think that quote might be talking
about stand up yeah
i wouldn't have dared to tell the funny
stories about him while he was alive i
don't think just on the risk
he he was offended or you know there'd
be consequences
what was he like for anybody that hasn't
read you about your story
um steroid taking shaven headed
silverback doorman right wing angry
council estate working class barbell
curl
semi-professional bodybuilder lifeguard
sheet metal worker lager
nutter by lager i don't mean someone who
gets on it i mean someone who puts
the insulation on the outside of pipes
the hardest job you can imagine crawling
in boilers
ripping out asbestos fiberglass cut
hands white transit van gaal it away
just massive shirts tail this is when
he's taking steroids that was
before i was born shirts tailored
trousers splitting hulk like at the
thigh just a force
of meat called dave that was my dad
actually call dave
dave actually called dave from essex
um so yeah he was just very old school
so even though
he's like more like someone who was born
in about 1920 he had sort of the
politics and the attitude very
unreconstructed masculinity
quite knuckle draggy but
just would just worked himself to death
to provide
barely raised his voice at me and
certainly never laid a finger on me but
didn't didn't need to
i find the truly terrifying cockney can
just give you summer you [ __ ] get in
near
now and you're you're done i i i i
actually pissed came out of my body once
when he spoke to me like that
really i literally pissed myself i was
i'd thrown my brother on the bed and he
was crying
and there's nothing scarier than hearing
though on the stairs if you've done
something to your brother or sister
and you know your dad's coming up the
stairs and he's like what happened what
have you done your brother had to piss
myself
and that guy never laid a finger on me
that's power my mom definitely laid her
finger
i don't think i would have been scared
of her if she didn't but i was [ __ ]
terrified of my mum
like but she she would beat me like but
my but i couldn't imagine
how she could have achieved that same
objective without
hitting me with something it's it's it
would be analogous of the nuclear
deterrent threat
if you know i've got nuclear weapons i
don't need to fire them for you not to
attack me so i know
i knew my dad had whereas i just sounds
incredibly sexist but the reality is
once you're a 14 15 year old lad
you're the same size as your mum there
are no you know
wearing the nuclear weapon she's got to
put her money where her mouth is but
haven't you got to know how nuclear
weapons work
to to know that they're i just
to be honest with you my dad's giving me
so many positive things it's just that
the negative things are funny
so that's why i talk about them
disproportionately but to teach someone
i'm five foot ten like a pepper army
with hair on but when i stand on
stage i don't need to hit people or
shout they
they sit in their seats and some of them
in the front row [ __ ] themselves if i
even look at them
so who have i learned that from it's
partly my craft
but it's partly also what a good teacher
has
uh what a good dad has like my dad and
what a good stand-up has
male or female that authority to stand
there and hold a room
with a reasonable tone in the voice pin
drop
is powerful it's harder for a mum to do
that particularly where i grabs a lot of
single mums
um when you've got teenage lads that are
sort of thinking what you're going to do
it becomes like an arms race where the
mum starts hitting the legs and hitting
the face
and it's needed because that's what the
mum's got to work with i suppose that's
why that's why i do believe this is so
sexist and old school
but i do believe if not a man
two parental figures in in place one who
can play the badass doesn't matter if
it's two women two
men whatever i think if you've got two
it's double the force raising a child
takes a village you i remember you know
the way you've described your dad is
um is quite different from who you are
today and who you are over the last
10 years i mean yeah and almost the
antithesis and i remember
reading about the fact that you took a
dna test at some point
i took a dna test just out of curiosity
because i'm big into
science i wanted to know what diseases i
was carrying
i've always been fascinated about my
ethnic makeup because my family history
starts in living memory i'm obviously a
little bit
darker than i should be to be a brit you
know i thought i
wanted i was interested to know what was
in there but
part of me did go what if this is the
moment i discover my dad's not my
my dad it did cross my mind which is
totally absurd sorry mum if you're
watching
um because he was blonde hair
blond curly hair blue eyes very
wide um it's just that which is not
nothing in common my brother is the
spirit of my dad
but i'm like i'm not my mum just
energetic pepper army with hair on
running around
bouncing out of bed stick first thing in
the morning and like
in terms of like generational cycles
where did
your dad get it from so he always used
to say to me i never had a dad
so why about okay so then my mum would
my mum would say so you've got to
understand your dad didn't
get taught how to be at my mum's game
man your mom didn't get talked
your mum did your dad didn't get taught
how to be a dad so he just know what he
didn't know how to be around babies he's
never learned that sort of thing he
never
he didn't have anyone to guide him so
quite a rough childhood
his dad walked out on him when he was
about i think he was about two
and my dad's mom's hard as nails he's
eastenders well his essex back then
barking
and it was just a tough childhood you
know tough east london
essex childhood where you you just
survived basically
and uh he he had a lot of
dreams i think he would have liked to
have gone the same way i did he was
quite a good-looking bloke so he got
scouted for modeling and things like
that he pursued that for a bit he'd
pursued the professional bodybuilding
even tried to stand up i think like a
pontins or a butlins he tried a little
bit of acting
only for a couple of years and then he
went into the hardest
i think of all the manual labour you can
do which is
sheet metal and insulation so that like
i say crawling along pipes and all that
so there's a lot of bitterness a lot of
unrealized dreams a lot of abandoned by
your dad a lot of
hardness and negativity there from the
childhood and that plagued him his whole
life
so if we were on a beautiful four-star
holiday to minorco and the sun shining
part of him would be thinking about the
five-star holiday he could have
i'm not like that at all how did you
know how did you know he was thinking
that
well he would voice it half the time how
what would he say
uh yeah it's all right imagine if i get
the big job imagine if we would come
back he'd be quite positive on holiday
actually
but he was like just imagine julie if we
if we had more math my mom of course
julian dave
if we had more money that house we could
have and my mom would be like dave we
bought our own council house thanks
thatcher it's a big
house the biggest house in the street
we've got pillars out the front yes it's
a former council house we've got pillars
we've got a swimming pool in the garden
three beautiful bedrooms lovely bathroom
massive house dining room front room
two healthy sons at the point my brother
was very unwell by the time he was 17
but at that point
what was there to be negative about my
it's hard job my dad did but
good money but he couldn't see that he
could just see his mate who started a
glass company and now his son drove a
lambo and he lived in chickwell and
i don't and when my dad passed away we
were going through the shed at the
bottom of the garden and i found his
diary
and it was lit it was honestly it was
one of the few things that made me cry
when he died because i sort of toughened
up to help with the funeral all that
because my brother was ill by then
and uh it's just rained today didn't get
the job
[ __ ] day james being a can i swear yeah
james being a [ __ ] and that's my brother
[ __ ] day
[ __ ] curry it was like the diary of
someone
in prison that's what it was like it was
it's so weird that someone could be rich
and not know it
i love making money don't get me wrong
but i'm really good
at enjoying what i've got so i've
enjoyed every level of my comedy journey
and i've never been bothered about
whether i go further or not because i
feel like if you can have two banging
holidays a year
and you love the house you're living in
and your family is healthy done
he was engaging in upward social
comparisons right the whole time and if
you do that you're never going to be
happy absolutely and you see that with
people
in in my profession that are earning a
million pounds a year two million a year
when they're in debt
because they're buying an ap watch every
week and they're going to the maldives
four times a year and they've got
they're in a 10 million pound house so
they should be in a 5 million pound it's
ridiculous
that's consumerism but it worked on a
more micro level
so we would if we're going to stanton
airport to fly to menorca
traffic's probably going to be [ __ ] on
the way to the airport i bet you the
traffic will be [ __ ] so we're already
he's pre-imagining the traffic jam will
be in
if we hit a traffic jam [ __ ] knew it
holiday we'll probably miss the flight
holidays [ __ ] julie i [ __ ] told you
we should have gone for
i [ __ ] told you he didn't shout maybe
he would shout to himself sort of thing
did you ever figure out where he learnt
that behavior where that came from no
idea like i said it was just
all the bitterness and negativity and
expecting things to go wrong
that was his tape his script so if we
were in a restaurant and
i'd be seven years old and i'd spill a
glass of water not coke or anything so
he's not gonna get sticky legs
he'd be like water everywhere a [ __ ]
meal ruin i've got to sit here like i
pissed myself for the entire movie
it'll be like the worst thing in the
world has happened like someone at that
moment's probably found
a lump on their body but to my dad the
worst thing that can happen
so he i felt sorry looking back now
you've got you've got to feel compassion
and love
because it was just a constant tide of
self-hate and negativity basically and
imagining
if we go and buy um something from ikea
that needs putting up
you know a screw will be missing and
it's because i'm me because i'm
cursed the [ __ ] screw will be missing
you can guarantee it
[ __ ] that all the time so for a
little boy growing up you've got to work
really hard
not to absorb that i i see hints of that
in my dad especially as he got older a
little bit more negative about
everything
moods you know seem to be irritable at a
lot of things and one of the things that
crossed my mind was
i hope this isn't genetic like how do i
avoid
becoming this guy when i get to that age
has that crossed your mind that
the generational cycle might
continue to some degree without you
noticing
obviously yeah i mean see him so my
brother i don't i can't really go into
my brother's illness because he's
literally not well enough to consent for
me to talk about it
otherwise i would happily discuss it
because it's an important subject to
talk about but he's got
some severe mental health issues let's
just leave it there so my brother's
really sort of
unrefreshingly unaware of his mannerisms
and gestures and postures if you like
and it's just like my he's like my old
man
so how can your like the way
your voice and the cadence of a sentence
and the glances and the way you
you say no i mean and stuff like that it
is my old man
so i mean on some genetic level there
are copies of
how we express ourselves there must be
but
apart from maybe your height
i can't think of anything you can't
change with
loads of loads of ways education
cognitive behavioral therapy if you need
it i never have but you can
um you can work on the way you eat your
diet your lifestyle all of those
you know genetics is not destiny one of
the most fascinating things you can look
up is identical twin studies over and
over again
you'll get one twin that's two inches
taller than the other
where he's had a more successful not two
inches but it might be an inch taller
where he's had a more successful life
eating better food so you can literally
grow taller
they're they're genetically identi
identical so you can't tell me i'm
destined
to suddenly be negative about traffic
jams if two identical twins can
be different in height you must be able
to push against behavior
you see that film through identical
strangers yes fantastic yeah amazing
absolutely fantastic yeah yeah made me
upset
yeah it's inspired chris you know the
ending is obviously tragic but uh
yeah really powerful film and i think
that shines a light on how it does
it gives hope for all of us that you're
not you're only 50
of your dad and 50 of your mum and uh
although you're actually slightly more
of your your mom i've learned how anyway
but um so you don't you're not if you're
only 50
if twins aren't destined to be the same
you're not destined to be the same as a
parent it's it's
it's bad it's a bad way to think
particularly if it's a negative it's a
good way to think if there's something
you want to copy tell yourself it chant
it
you want to be more like my mom she's
such a cool cat or whatever
we we have also grown up in a slightly
different culture especially in the last
sort of 10 20 years where we're much
more aware of our psychology right
and our and our and how trauma and
childhood experiences have shaped us as
adults
whereas i think my dad probably didn't
know so it was like
someone back there in the control room
running the show without him and he was
just a puppet to the [ __ ] he'd been
through whereas we are kind of a bit
more open as a society now so
yeah that that's my biggest learning
men's mental
health comes on the spectrum it doesn't
mean mentally if we have mental health
everyone has men if we have physical
health we have mental health
even if you have no issues that's good
you are mental health
so mental health runs on on a spectrum
to people that
are cooking on for hobbs like me and you
hopefully
all the way down to people like my
brother who are severely severely ill
with cognition issues
and people who are severely ill or
people who are trapped in time
like our dads before an awakening they
don't have
insight into their current state if you
do not have
insight into your condition you are
screwed because if you're let's say for
example schizophrenic
without insight into the fact you have
schizophrenia you will not take the
medicine
you just won't take it you'll look at
the pill and go well i don't
i'm not healed so you'll you'll be in
assisted accommodation your entire life
if you're schizophrenic but know you
have schizophrenia chances are you can
have a relatively normal life because
you know
i'm i need to take my medicine and that
but you can translate that thinking
to any aspect of business or commerce to
stand-ups to entrepreneurs
because i've noticed i call it black box
thinking from the matthew syed book
the moment you can have insight into a
stand-up routine
or into a business proposition in a
proper way where you can look it and go
that doesn't work
you're going to be successful people
that don't have insight into themselves
in their personal lives they end up
single they end up in unhappy
relationships
because they can't see their own
thoughts they can't insight into
themselves and go this
quick one starting from the minute the
lockdown is lifted we're going to start
bringing in some of our subscribers to
watch how this podcast is produced
behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
i mean this is just an impossibly tough
question yeah because we're talking
about self-awareness really right so
like how does and people
people have asked me this question for
the last five years and i really don't
have a great answer still
how does one become more self-aware well
i it was literally part of my degree
i'm very lucky here we go i started
doing english literature because i
wanted to do the most show-off on
council estate posh subject possible way
i mean i was going to get a first or i
was i don't know what was going to
happen so i told myself i'm going to get
a first amount what
that was pre-ordained
so i did two years of showing off about
you know roland bartz and jane austen
and all that and there was an
opportunity in the last year
to cross over into creative writing and
the reason i did that
is again goes back to my dad it's not
very practical to be absolutely badass
on jane austen unless you're going to
want to be a lecturer or an academic
whereas creative writing um is a
practical profession
you can go into advertising you can go
into journalism you can try and write
books you can as it turns out go into
stand-up i didn't know that yet
there's loads of places where you can go
look i've not just got a first in
english
i've got a first in in writing i can
take body copy and make your
brand pop so par
how do you do a dissertation in creative
writing there's only one way
you have to submit ten thousand words
normal academic pouncing about and you
have to submit ten thousand word short
story play
but you have to run through your own
work and criticize it and say what you
got right and what you got wrong
once you've been through that and done
it loads of times
it just becomes natural to bring it to
your life a copywriter in an advertising
agency has to be able to
really hate his own work he just created
and
find the faults in it because that will
lift it above
ogilvy's copywriter and you'll win the
pitch
it's as simple as that the person the
man who cannot realize he's domineering
or jealous and work on that
will not have a fruitful relationship
woman or a man indeed in order to do
that with your life or with your copy or
with your work or whatever in marketing
you have to have a certain level of
self-esteem and personal security to be
to allow yourself to rise above your
work and look back down on it in a
critical way a lot of people's
self-esteem are so fragile
yeah that the prospect of being critical
is uh it's just unthinkable
like you know this is why people get to
from my experience where people get so
defensive and
because they're because they're so if
you one shot to their self-esteem will
take the whole house down
so that they immediately go like this
hat likes so you could look at it that
way
so i would say that person needs to
learn not
self-esteem because self-esteem's a
totally different conversation
they need to learn objectivity a piece
of writing is a thing
a relationship is a thing that you've
built with someone
a comedy routine is a thing a poem is a
thing the things over there that's not
you
you have to practice being able to take
the piss out of the thing
criticize the thing no someone's not
coming up to you and going you're ugly
um you're unlovable uh you've got a big
nose you're not tall enough stuff like
that
is gonna hurt and there's no way of
getting objective but if you can't look
at a poem you've written and someone
goes i really love the meter but the
adjective there's a bit obvious
then you should be able to thank that
person they're giving you a gift
if they know their [ __ ] but you're the
one that should be saying that first
eminem style eight mile seize the bars
and turn them on yourself first
hard to do because everything is better
it makes better work it makes better
humans
yeah i completely agree it's just really
tough to do like
practice it's practice i get a lot of um
i this is the message i get most often
sent to me by my agent or an instagram
and it drives me [ __ ] nuts i had one
the other week
oh my god i love what you do i'm i'm a
really funny person this is how it was
phrased the other week
how how many gigs would i have to do
before i
could like open for you on tour can you
have a look at some stuff i filmed on my
phone
and i'm i'll give them an answer that
norm i never get a reply to this answer
i say okay it's quite simple lucky for
you there is a really simple model to
follow you need to work
unpaid for three years in the clubs
three times a week
i wouldn't recommend a relationship and
just warn your friends you're not gonna
see them
i started to earn about two three
hundred pounds a week after five years
at that point you're ready to give up
your day job on about the eighth or
ninth year
you're going to be ready to do a support
slot i never go
yeah people don't want to hear it but
you if you went up to the guy in the gym
who's 16 stone and five percent body fat
and can you tell me how i can get like
that you'd say the machines are over
there [ __ ] just get going
yeah the machines are there you cannot
skip the machine you cannot skip the
tricep
station if you want triceps you can't
just go but it's going to hurt
uh it's too much work to get attracted
then just don't get triceps don't but
don't moan if you don't have triceps
head to the dip station and see you in
four years
i completely yeah i now i've wrote about
this my book came out last week and i
wrote about it in my book i remember
someone turning to me was actually the
ceo of my company now
company i've just left and he said to me
steve you know this personal brand stuff
and this like speaking you do on stage
was like how long did it like how did
what he was like how do i
how do i do it and your brain
immediately scrambles around looking for
like three tips
right three tips to describe like a deck
i remember my first
talk in school at 14 years old my hand's
shaking absolutely the truth is like
someone's seen you with a sharp sword
and they've said how do i get a short
sword that sharp
i said well start sharpening it now and
then ten years time but
people don't work no one wants to hear
the answer is
boring repetitive practice for most most
people that are absolutely
[ __ ] excellent at something have done
a lot of boring
repetitive practice that would be boring
to the person asking the question not to
us
i loved every [ __ ] gig i did and that's
the difference that's what kept you
doing it for 10 years or
two decades whatever is that you
genuinely intrinsically loved it for its
and people want the rewards right but
when they if they started and genuinely
wanted they too would discover that love
if you if you say i want to be an
identity i'd be a dentist you start
dental training and you're finding it
boring in a slog
news flash you don't actually want to be
a dentist you'll be rich
yeah so find something else find
something where you love the journey
that is a secret so that's what my dad
never found he did he didn't find a job
he took pleasure in he's got nothing to
do with coin although i'm into it
but if you love the outdoors you're
going to love landscaping whether you're
on 17 grand a year or 17 million a year
you're gonna love it because that's what
you were born to do it's such a
counter narrative to the narrative that
sells which is like short investment big
so it's like seven days six pack abs
that's everyone [ __ ] signs up for
that
imagine imagine that the like
10 years maybe maybe that's true
and that's and the problem is a lot of
the t the tv
we make i make sells that x factor spot
do one song
live the pimp lifestyle and of course
that is what in the
all of the x factor that's ever been on
and all of pop star the rivals
how many of those people are now
platinum selling artists living in
mansions
what harry styles try and name some
one direction that's it that's out of
every
single little mixed doomer that's out of
every single one
in a show that's designed to push people
to the front in an artificial way
so if you think that's going to happen
if you're russell from
essex you're deluded it's
but any business if you're passionate
mixed with a little bit of luck people
this is the other thing people like us
don't like putting out there but i'm
afraid
there is a bit of luck involved
and it sort of causes like we always sat
here again i've worked so hard oh look
at me with my work hard badge but at
some point we had some luck as well
which is we're in the right place right
time
mixed with the hard work so some people
are more lucky than others luck
is a thing and what lucky
not luck as in lottery number luck but
luck is in oh my god you've met that
you've met the perfect partner you
you've been the business oh you you were
looking for a friend a french bulldog
breeder and you found exactly the right
one at the right time when you were
looking for a puppy why are you so lucky
where's my life so [ __ ]
so they tested this they got a bunch of
people together
half people who say my life [ __ ] i'm so
unlucky and half people like me who like
i've gotta admit i'm a bit
hashtag blessed i do have a lot of luck
and they run tests on them
and the test they run was very simple
the the psychologist i come here is the
british jewish guy really funny brings
loads of books out richard something or
other he's written a book about it about
luck look it up
they gave them newspaper each and they
went in there
go into your separate rooms and on a
page is a picture you're looking for
whoever finds that picture
comes in first gets a hundred pounds
cash that was the game
so everyone went in like that on page
two your massive headlines was it's a
trick
stop turning if you've read this
headline go and collect the money that
was on page two
all the unlucky people missed that all
the lucky people found it you know why
because lucky people
eyes are open the hustlers
so it turns out you can make luck you
can practice that you can hone it
that's something you can hone next time
you walk into a meeting
just think right what's that guy do for
it for a living who's that is that a
contact
that's not luck if i sit down next to
someone and he happens to be doing a
comedy streaming
service start up and he signs me up
that's me being a bit bold and striking
up a conversation and looking at what
he's wearing and having to think
you can learn these skills people don't
like that because that
sharp puts the mirror on me and creates
personal responsibility where i
yeah you know what i mean and i feel
like in our society at the moment this
is just an observation i've had
personal responsibility is people
[ __ ] hate that
yeah i did i remember doing a tweet
about um
because okay this was me playing a bit
of [ __ ] but i don't care right so
the left of society which i probably
consider myself to be on
are really in support of the nhs so i
did a tweet saying
the biggest cost to the nhs is like
smoking eating bad etc so if you really
care about the nhs
take care of yourself people like no
steve this is
literally the replies like this is not
it because i'm basically saying if you
genuinely care about the
health service here is all the data the
biggest burden on the nhs is people that
are overweight and
people that are smoking or whatever um
well the obesity one's particularly
controversial because there's two
movements at the same time
there's personal responsibility in the
science we're learning about obesity
particularly during covid
i mean if you if you want to do one
thing other than social distancing
obviously get a vaccine
most of us are too young to have a
vaccine so if you have another vaccine
and you don't and you don't want to live
life like a prisoner the best thing you
can do is get in shape
quick you're better off you're literally
better off being
i think a thin smoker literally yeah
but it's a controversial conversation
because quite rightly we're
re-evaluating beauty
standards and a lot of people end up
with eating disorders and fat shaming
and all that needs to go away
and as as soon as we associate
personal responsibility longevity in
health with a body type
we're in a difficult area where we
create
shame for people based on how they look
which is something you want to get rid
of so
for someone like me who's on on the left
my head just goes pop yeah
smoking is is a slam dunk don't smoke
your rebellion yeah
yeah end off [ __ ] don't smoke stop
costing me money on the nhs
but someone that might be overweight
it's
very very complex to understand why
someone's overweight
it's something i studied a lot not
because i've been overweight but because
i'm fascinated with biohacking and body
and all of that
and i think the most
most illuminating thing i can tell
anyone about being overweight
is that eating too much
does not make you overweight
this is no one understands this i'm
going to blow your mind here
being overweight causes you to eat
too much once you have the metabolic
condition
of being overweight that [ __ ] your
circuitry which drives you to eat
more obesity causes
calorie surplus so shaming people for
eating too much is a waste of time
because most people with busy lives and
kids and no money
are in a condition that's compelling
them to eat more might be
emotionally compounded might be
psychologically compounded they might be
recovering from abuse they might be
recovering from a bad relationship they
might just be skin and can only afford
[ __ ] nuggets and they're just tired
and not getting enough sleep
and unfortunately until you get into um
a low-fat state like us where it's easy
to regulate your calorie your
every part of your body is telling you
to feed this obesity
no one understands that i've gone deep
into the sign i'm not a scientist so
look up for yourself before everyone
starts trolling me saying literature
degree boy
but as far as i understand the science
layman's cards and table
obesity causes overeating now that is
just
boom but it helps us to be more as much
as i agree with what you're saying
it just it levens more compassion into
people's weight loss journey although
you're absolutely correct if you don't
want to die of covid
and you don't want to cost the nhs money
getting in shape's one of the best ways
to do it but of course it's not easy and
i've i've had moments in my life where
i've been most stressed
and it's a downward cycle yeah like you
know what i mean so you eat and then
you require sugar more and sugar becomes
this addictive thing in your life
and it only happens to me when i'm
stressed so i'll have my little moments
of downward cycle
in my health when there's a lot on my
mind
and so yeah i mean compassion is
certainly incredibly important in that
regard what about more broadly so
outside of health the topic of personal
responsibility i like it because it's
controversial mm-hmm
um and i discuss the new trying to get
us in the daily mail here
in fact people should pay for themselves
no i know just generally in your life
and success in like
um what you can accomplish the fortunate
position i'm in which is what i talked
about in my last podcast was
because i came from like a very broke
family where my mum can't read or write
and i i was born in africa
and i we didn't have anything no
christmas birthdays or holidays my
journey in life people don't discredit
it they don't point at me and say oh
you know silver spoon you can't [ __ ]
talk yep so
i feel like i can have the conversation
a little bit more about personal
responsibility of course i'm [ __ ]
incredibly lucky
like i didn't choose to be me you know
what i mean i didn't choose my parents
or the
good and bad things that shaped me yeah
but i but i wanna
i wanna have a conversation about
personal responsibility as it relates to
career success and let's let's start
with hard work
because in our society right now there's
two counter narratives one is that
don't work like incredibly hard you're
gonna burn out and you're gonna have
mental health problems and the other is
i've never met someone that sat here
in front of me that doesn't work really
[ __ ] hard and i i did
i don't know how i would have sat here
without hard work and tremendous
sacrifice well first of all we sort of
already made the point
a lot of people are working hard at
things they hate yeah
so working hard at things you dislike
hate or find stressful
will bring success and money but at a
cost
working hard at things you love i'm i
finished filming at midnight last night
in madison i got in at half one i had my
dinner at two
and i fell asleep at three and i bounced
out of bed this morning to come here to
do
a podcast for the price of a car why
because
i love what i do now if i was
had got in at three from working as a
hospital porter
and had to get up to do another job
which was quite well paid this morning
but i hated it
i wouldn't be buzzing and that's what
releases the cortisol and the stress
hormone into your body
so you can't compare you're not
comparing like and like even though both
people are working hard you've even got
people
that might be barristers or doctors
really well paid professions but find it
stressful when they're burnt out and
stuff
it's unlikely you and i will burn out
because i'm like what's next
and you're intrinsically motivated by
you've got a sense of control
exactly so that's that's what i think
that
i think we can we can differentiate
there on hard work
straight away so if i i'm more
interested in the first thing you said
about the
the join between people's origin story
and how much stick they get for the
success they've got because i'm
i have to phrase mine a lot more than
you
because i get put in with the silver
spoon guys because i'm a
just a white man yeah so i'm not going
to use real names here and i'm not going
to use real jobs because i respect
my profession is so hard i don't give a
[ __ ] whether you're
prince charles doing stand up anyone who
does stand up
i just it's so hard to stand up
and i don't think an elite background
helps you in stand up might help you in
telly and production
won't help you on stage with a bucket of
piss coming through
but i've been told on more than one
occasion uh we'd love we'd love to
we'll book you for the x show but we've
already got ollie um and so we got ollie
we can't have two
and i'm like how how is how me do me and
ollie represent the same thing
i sometimes think well i've got more in
common with
i could phone up i don't know if you
know who judy love is i could phone up
judy now and we could speak for an
hour about we both grew up same similar
part of london
similar age similar family yes she's got
jamaican stories but i've got six
stories
and that's the only difference in our
conversation we come from the same
place economically we come with fighting
the same fight we're punching up from
when we never no one would ever say that
i'll probably be in trouble for even
saying that
that's the controversial thing for me to
say and it shouldn't be
because if corbyn and people like that
have got it right
everyone who starts with what i call
lower entitlement points
i've got a lot more entitlement points
than a woman of color
undoubtedly i've got less less
entitlement points
probably than a ghanaian prince right so
all the people that have got
[ __ ] all uh i'll start should link arms
don't matter what gender you are
what color you are that would be
powerful i'm a bit nervous when we get
carved up and we're people who started
life in a tower block should that tower
block should be united you know what i
mean
so that's the first point but i do i do
think you we get off
we do get off lightly if we've got money
if we had a more council estate
background it's like a license
to be okay with having money like i can
wear my rolly by the pool when i'm in
ibiza
because i sound common yeah if i sounded
posh
i probably would keep the breitling on
yeah
it's so true i one of one of my guests
that i had on the podcast
um went to a very good school and
um is white and blonde and very pretty
and she basically can't give advice
to anybody without the papers smashing
her
or social media in fact there was a meme
before before she came on the podcast
there was a meme that went viral i think
it did 250 000 retweets
when she the day she released her book
and it was this someone
pinned someone up against the wall with
a big trumpet and it was like white
privilege telling you how to
how to become rich like she is not
allowed to give advice to anybody
because she's white and went to a good
oxford and with how much good insight
and business knowledge and whatever
like so many people went to oxford and
didn't build multi multi-million
pound two multi-million pound companies
i still want to hear this from this
person if someone's offering you
knowledge
she's not it's not like she's telling
you about her struggles earlier
there was a queue in waitress and i just
couldn't keep that that would be the
trumpet
right she's trying to tell you how to
build a business it doesn't matter if
you come from space
if you can make me money tell me how if
you can tell me how to start the next
comedy streaming platform service where
i own
40 of the shares yeah i don't give a
[ __ ] if you've got a double first from
cambridge
or whether you're one of the mandem i
don't care show me where to
show me how to do it you've got you've
got to have an open
knowledge is is once it's out there is
democratic the path to acquiring it is
not
um but there's no doubt about trying to
stay on topic what you're saying about
personal responsibility
is i'm really split on this because i
don't believe it's true
that anyone with enough will and luck
can make it i think we're probably
outliers and freaks and
just wired a bit different and i've got
what it takes to push through
i think if enough blocks are in place
you're a single child of a drug using
mum in a towel block
and i am built of stronger stuff so i've
bounced through my childhood
and i've come out the other side but a
lot of people aren't if we were all born
the same
then why aren't i playing basketball why
am i not sprinting why am i not
a math scholar you know some of us are
born
genetically more equipped in other
departments i'm clearly a highly
energetic person
who's good at motivating themselves some
part of that is inborn i was like
i would like it as a baby before i could
speak you know the other toddlers are
like
dribbling on their blocks and i'm like
where the blood set
so it's unfair for us to go if only
uh neil at the top of the tower could
have been like us he too could have
been an entrepreneur because maybe he
just being a single mom
being of color or being transgender or
being
not everyone has the strength to push
through those
things not everyone does and it's unfair
to go up to a wheelchair and go just
stand mate i'm using willpower with my
legs why can't you
because some people that that is a
wheelchair their social background and
they don't have the strength and then
they start using drugs and they just
sink too low
not everyone can pull themselves out so
that's why we do need more equality
yeah i agree i'm definitely pro-quality
i i there's a sense of helplessness i
get
if i like if i go all the way and say
you know successful people well they
were born with something yeah it creates
a sense of like well then you're we're
all just stuck in our lanes forever and
if i believe that when i was shoplifting
pizzas in manchester
but then again what i do understand i
actually when i re the harder i reflect
i basically give myself credit for
nothing because i was born into a
situation in a country
i actually think my bad experiences are
why i'm here like the fact that my
parents
weren't around at 10 years old created
this big gap of independence et cetera
et cetera i've told this story a million
times
but it's the bad [ __ ] that is the reason
that i became an outlier i think
i became very obsessive obsessed with
money my book that's why it's called
happy sexy millionaire because it's the
first page of my diary when i was like a
kid
i want to be a happy why did i want to
be happy sexy because we were [ __ ]
broke have you got siblings though yeah
i've got
so are they happy 60 millionaires not
one of them none of them are like me
and they don't understand me either they
look at me and like scratch their heads
but what does that tell you it's almost
like you've run a controlled experiment
exactly so tuning out um genetics versus
willpower i the the difference between
my childhood experience and theirs was
they were raised by parents and i
basically wasn't
so by i was the youngest so by the age i
was 10 my parents were like oh we've
done parenting now
we will work all the time and we will be
out of the house when steve comes home
and will be at the house when he wakes
up
so i was the only one where the the
experiment was
total independence so thought experiment
for you if you'd have been born a
fraternal twin
another boy yeah so as much your brother
brothers your other brothers but happy
boy at the same time
same conditions same school everything
happens so do you believe you would have
another happy sexy millionaire living in
the flat opposite
or do you think depends what that
brother's personality was like
because we both know that that brother's
personality is what would have decided
whether he sat at this table with us
today or not and
personality does come into it we are
born with different
personalities to an extent so i'm not
saying we're all stuck in our lanes
but i'm saying we need more social
mechanisms because
some einsteins don't have energy some
einsteins might might be a bit
emotionally weaker so we're saying my
example of neil at
the tower block he might be really
[ __ ] amazing we will never harvest
that talent because our society is set
up with too many blocks in place
to scoop it out we had one thing in
place for about 40 years
called grammar schools very
controversial
very unfair dumping a load of 11 year
olds in the thick bin
my mum went to a secondary modern my dad
went to a secondary modern
my wife my brother-in-law my
mother-in-law and father-in-law
all went secondary moderns so i know
people who were told you're no good at
11. so i don't say this lightly and i
know how horrific that is
but the data does suggest that
there was a short period where we
scooped off some
bright poorer children not necessarily
neil in the tower block
but at least the poorer children whose
parents
meant well but were too poor we got them
we got more einsteins
when you watch question time switch it
on and you know i went to a state school
and they're giving it all that will
always be a grammar school
always is very rarely i went to the
local comprehensive and now i'm an mp
it's always
i went to state which state school it's
gramsci you went to an elite education
then state but elite selective
so we need some more stuff like that
what can we do in our communities what
can our youth workers do what
what can we set up in in in council
estates
headhunters that look for talent
particularly boys
i'm going to say that because i was a
boy once but there's a real problem with
teenage boys all this testosterone kicks
in and it goes the wrong
way for most of us you when i came in
your podcast you ask
very controversial questions i think you
like those questions those are the ones
that are most interesting to you aren't
they yeah well
as long as it gets in trouble well it's
hard to tell
hindsight's a wonderful thing um so i
guess my i was just thinking then this
is a controversial question but he asked
me controversial questions so i can
answer it
is there no hope for some people well
give me con so zoom out context got a
friend
tried really hard to help them change
their life or do something for
themselves
10 years of effort made all the offers
in the world to this person
still job seekers allowance you know
somewhat depressed can't seem to have
any impact we grew up in the same street
we were best friends my whole childhood
i went off he stayed there
i've got tons of examples like that so i
have to speak very euphemistically now
i'll be cancelled not by the internet
but by my
friends and family stroke associate
stroke i don't even want to say which
group these people are
uh i've all of this i've had female
friends who i'm like
stop dating bastards and the next guy
he's nice he's a coke dealer and he's
like he's gonna [ __ ] he's clear he's
gonna shaggy mate
and some of these women are getting to
35 you know like with the final
egg in the goblet like in indiana jones
waiting to be fertilized
and um this the next guy he's called
we've got three kids by three different
women he has
he's got an electronic tag but it's
great because we can spend some time
just bang a boring guy or a guy that
likes dungeons and dragons or an
accountant
what they call there's a sexual
attraction there
to bastard men that some women
particularly from high school background
working class women
find hard to get over would be one
example but you can
get over it it is possible to do it the
mistake people like you and i
make is we try to help
and say you've got a friend who's
unmotivated depressed
leaves every job after three months it's
always someone else's fault
it's always the system it's always if
only corbyn was in power
it's uh my dad did this my mum did that
always putting it on someone else and
then you're making it worse by putting
it on you let me help
you're just a positive version of that
the solution is with them
they have to switch the light bulb on in
themselves
they may not get there but the moment
they wake up and go today's the day i'm
gonna try and change my life
they should that the first step it might
be
speaking to a therapist it might be
changing your career it might be
enrolling in a levels that you do at
night time like i did
that was what lucky enough my revelation
came up when i was
you're on job seekers allowance at one
point i was yeah i did my a-levels late
because i had this
spark moment but it's got to come from
within them it's not something
as yet although science might get there
one day but we can give to you in a pill
or an injection you've got to suddenly
have in right back to the beginning of
the chat
insight and baby like boom chest out i'm
going to see a therapist
i'm not going to use negative language
i'm going to get this self-help book
which
which gives me some cb cognitive
behavioral therapy tools i always hung
up with cannabis
um so yeah it's it's gonna come from
them but for you and i
fixes how can we solve it how can i
redraft the copy what's the solution
unfortunately the solution is trying to
get them
to have some insight so if you have got
a friend like that maybe have that sort
of conversation with them that spurs
self-reflection
because giving them a million pound a
year job is just going to make them
worse because that muscle that's
atrophied
will stay atrophied that sort of
standing up
making your own strength muscle i've
been on my heel journey for a couple of
years now but in the case of some of my
best friends who i've talked about on
this podcast before
one particular friend called ashley
jones who knows that i talk about him in
his transformation story
he did have a problem eating certain
foods
and so he transitioned to making huel a
greater part of his diet and the guy
went from being and i'm sorry ash if
you're listening
the guy went from being like slightly
overweight constantly
um having health issues that are
unrelated to like you know being
slightly overweight
to being to literally having a six-pack
posting his six-pack on instagram but
more importantly
being high-energy and feeling amazing so
when i'm like
you know talking to you guys about huel
i do so with such a level of passion
because i believe
that it can really help change your
lives in a significant way
i believe it can make you mentally
better i know it can make you physically
better
and so yeah what a joy it is to have a
sponsor that you believe in that much
um yeah and they're also just really
good people
one of the most um probably
scary things from my perspective that
you ever did
was walking out on stage for the first
time for your first gig ever
like what the [ __ ] were you thinking hmm
going out and walking in front of people
and telling [ __ ] jokes are you sure
like
with me it's even more complex because i
don't know if you've had any stand-ups
on here before
never but the majority of them and quite
rightly so
will be like from a young age i used to
watch blah blah on tv
i used to watch all these american
comics so i used to watch chris rock
bill burr
bill hicks i knew that's what i wanted
to do man
i was like you know i was like the young
boxer in the alleyway i knew i was to
box
none of that nothing there is zero
in my cv that shows an affinity for the
craft of stand up
always been the joker i'm not being
funny today i don't know why you got me
on one
but normally i'm always asking around
not this is not a thing i do on stage
i'm just i'm not like
the clown person why just just my again
i've just always been
i just love making people laugh i've
always been a joker
there's some data that suggests um
youngest children have it and i'm not
the youngest child the oldest or
people born in august and july purely
because
if you're smaller than everyone else
you've got to develop your personality
quick
so you if you look at the premiership
you won't find many footballers
born in august i'll explain why i never
made it
august august 26th so you won't find me
sixth as well you won't find
many sportsmen or anyone that requires
size or physical prowess those
professions
so even if you turn out to be a very
tall teenager
you're less likely to become a
basketball player than a
a teenager one inch shorter than you who
was born in october
the reason being you'd have been pushed
by the coach and taught and everything
early doors at six seven eight years old
so and there is some data to suggest
that people who work with their
personalities for a living people that
have to solve entrepreneurs and find
little
rat runs in alleyways develop that based
on being smaller or more vulnerable but
i could take lots of forms i've got an
overbearing dad as well
so i'm an august baby overvaling dad and
some of you will be genetic
my mum's very funny you talked a little
bit about i was reading some some of
your
um previous interviews you talked a
little bit about how it was a bit of a
defense mechanism maybe in school if
that's
you found your name yes by being a yeah
i wasn't but but i don't know how i
wasn't bullied
but i wasn't the smallest no girlfriend
um wasn't him with the in crowd at all i
was sort of like an ex
in a sort of external group that had
diplomatic immunity
definitely a virgin definitely no cool
friends
definitely one of the idiots but we
don't punch him because he's sort of all
right
obviously i did get as a working class
school i did get punched a lot but not
as much as
i was in that league you probably won't
even remember them just above the bullet
the boring grey league no point
yeah which is the place to be at school
because if you're popular at school we
all know
you're gonna have a [ __ ] life
so anyway so because of where i grew up
it's not people like well how can you
have no contact with stand up so you
gotta remember my age i know i look
young
young for my age i'm 45. so
what was my dad watching on tv jim
davison bernard manning
jimmy jones it's like bruce forsyth and
jimmy tarbuck
like you know live at the palladium and
all that it's not obviously they're all
talented comedians and i do i do mean
that
but it just didn't resonate with what
it's not it's not about my life so
i'd like i'd laugh because my dad was
laughing but i was like what's this
crazy art form i've got to learn more
me and my friends mostly either smoking
it's all about getting high
or we'd watch old young ones or whatever
the funny sitcom of the day was maybe
even badly whatever it was
that's what i thought comedy was no we
didn't go to the theater of the weekend
we didn't know which cultural pursuit
should we do this weekend family it was
like dad works all week he's tired we
have a curry
nan looks after you and then when you
get to 15 16 you get stoned over the
park
get someone pregnant work in a shop die
that's it that's the finish line
so i managed to like i say have this
weird entrepreneur turn my life around
get my first class degree
moment but just by sheer bad luck i
ended up at a university that did not
have a stand-up night most of them do
so again i went those three years
without any exposure to
in the student bar stand up it was all
music there was some theater
no one talked about stand up we didn't
have this sort of slightly fashionable
thing now being obsessed with american
stand-ups i like to say to my british
colleagues just remember
if you start having this sort of slick
quality to your stand up it can look a
bit mannered
um that's just a side point so i went
all the way to the office to my dream
job as an advertising copywriter with no
content we stand up just being funny as
[ __ ] the clown
you know legend on a night out first one
up dancing but i didn't know that
something you could do for a living and
i ended up doing a job i loved
branding copywriting headlines i still
love it you can tell by
the way i'm describing it then the
creative planner was like you're always
the one up at the pitch issue
i would do like if we're pitching to a
big client i would do like the funny bit
with interaction to get them on the side
when i'm presenting the creative he said
why don't you try stand up
stephen workman if you're watching thank
you uh why do you use chase stand up
with your mind's glass region
and i thought you know what do it once
like doing a bungee jump or a skydive
or karaoke it's just that's as far as my
thinking went
something to tell the kids so i wrote a
few ideas down in a book
booked an open spot in and i went and
did it it was very scary i think i did a
pack of imodium before i went on
and my hand was shaking and i got that
it wasn't obviously wasn't great but i
did wear
ish well-ish first laugh was like
someone stuck
cocaine heroin ketamine everything in my
but not that i've done those drugs
but everything in my veins and i was
hooked you know in the proper sense of
that
it [ __ ] my life everything fell apart
like a junkie how can i get more of that
i want a gig three night i want to give
five nights a week for no money
i've got a creative director we're
talking about multi multi-million pound
accounts
advertising is you work till 8 pm you
have pizza on your birthday under your
table you sleep at the office
i'm running off to do unpaid gigs in
manchester my relationship with my
girlfriend fell apart
my bill started to not be paid i started
to look thin because i
suffered with my nerves in the beginning
i'm throwing up [ __ ] like both ends
it's the closest thing to a drug
addiction that i've ever experienced
i would have not seen my mum for a year
to chase this
dream it was i was hooked with on that
laugh
i'm like this is what i'm born to do i
just [ __ ] know it how can i
monetize it basically how why were you
hooked on the laugh why did the laugh
matter so much to you it's a rush
it's a rush anyone is i've not taken any
serious drugs but anyone that's taken
any recreational drugs which is a bad
analogy because they're not actually
addictive
but coffee for example i can't live my
life without
without it why are you addicted this is
as absurd as asking me why i'm addicted
to coffee
because i go i wake up i feel alive and
i have an amazing day
the same laugh goes in buzz uh
serotonin pupils dilated afterwards i
want to tell everyone about the gig i
was taking
[ __ ] footage into work and showing it to
people and playing it in the office look
at me
that's me look look come and look at me
in this grainy footage i mean that's so
embarrassing that i did that
i just i couldn't i just couldn't
believe it i couldn't believe
i was getting laughs from strangers it
was straight to the ego
straight to the cortex everyone has that
but do you
have you ever considered that you might
have that might have mattered more to
you
maybe because of your childhood or
whatever than other people that that
sense of like
that validation and that yeah i mean
maybe i mean i'd had plenty of
validation at work i'd had the whole
office cheer
i've rung the bell when we've won big
pitches i've got the rush in the meeting
but it nothing it it's the difference
i'm trying not to talk about drugs all
the time it's the difference between
going from a beer
to mdma right i don't
recommend any hard drugs obviously
particularly people that work with their
brains you're a fool if you mess with
the equipment
but you can't compare them when you say
everyone has that
not everyone stood on stage to a
thousand people
and seen people standing and clapping
that is different
it's of a different category of ego
rush very dangerous what problems does
it give you
well initially all has come with it
initially that my life felt
my life fell apart like a junkies i was
down to 10 stone at one point um
so it come to the point where i had to
say this needs to not be a drug this
needs to be a food
and i left the agency and then i was you
know
off still today though right so all all
things come with their
their costs what is the cost today of
that that career and that rush and that
i suppose the worst thing is the travel
that is a genuine negative one
since min has been born my daughter um i
actually quite
like traveling i like being in the back
of a car i love watching movies i love
reading
and i love eating on the move so all the
things that most people hate i just
happen to quite enjoy
just pure i don't know why because i'm
always on the go i like being forced to
sit still
and watch a movie so i love flights for
example the longer the better
um you still [ __ ] yourself now when you
get when you're about yes big time but
so far as so far as missing part of your
child growing
massive negative doing a is there's a
there's a guilt
thing in your gut and you know you do
cry a bit after facetiming that
particularly when it's a baby
so that's the biggest negative i can
think of but once you're with a woman or
a man
that gets it there's no negative in your
relationship i was with a couple of
girls before who would make me feel bad
about being away whereas lindsay's
kicking me out the door she's focused on
the business we're
a team that's well paid [ __ ] off see you
later
don't call home if you're stressed i'm
cool with it that's what you need man
you need someone who gets it
i do [ __ ] myself though still yes do you
know when you know the
the um a modium scale goes up depending
on how much of my show it is
so if you booked a show for me today
where you're going to introduce me and
i'm going to do 20 minutes stand up
and you've got 2 000 people in the room
there would be nerves there
a fair bit of nerves but mostly i'm
ready to
knock the gig the [ __ ] out with my first
punch if you've put an event on
and michael mcintyre is closing and
you're hosting it
and you to me at the last minute i said
russ i've decided to do two halves can
you do 20 minutes at the top i chip
myself
because they're not there for me they're
there for you and him and i've got a
conversion job to do
right and the risk is massive and then
michael's fans are your fans
and that's when the nerves kick in when
i'm doing royal variety show or live at
the apollo where people have responded
to a tv ticket not me that's when the
nerves go back to old school style
nerves
how how do you uh what's the battle you
have with those nerves and in terms of
your cognition and before you go on
stage what are the tips
you can give people a lot of people
there's two there's two ways to to
to work on that um the first thing is
the actual practical thing on the night
i would say
um just work with breathing and
mindfulness and all the stuff
you've probably read a thousand times
the other thing to do is if you can
find a way to do it it depends which
stage your career you're at if you're at
the stage of the career like me and you
a lot i'm not trying to be offensive a
lot of people are sucking addicts a lot
of the time
so we're constantly walking into the
rooms where people think we're legends
it's never going to be a difficult gig
now and again something comes up well
you're the tadpole and you
you don't have the hardware in place and
[ __ ] bill gates is speaking before
you oprah's hosting it and all of a
sudden you're who's this guy
you're having a day of who's this guy
we're all we can all have a who's this
guy dave
and the only way to practice that is to
put yourself
in more who's this guy moments regularly
so how i do that as soon as my tour
finishes i book
the smallest hardest weirdest
they might have bad lighting they might
have no microphone they might be half
sold
and i'm unlisted unlisted unannounced
unexpected and i walk on to tiny clubs
full of drunk
men 50 year old ukip dads
all of those places i put myself in
those all the time because the risk is
high the nerves are the same
but the consequence is zero so i'm
constantly training the muscle of
convert the people who don't know who i
am keeping it sharp the whole time
so whatever business you're in you'll be
able to think of an equivalent way of
doing that
so set up smaller situations where
you're having to keep that muscle
because the danger is the more
successful you get
you lose the muscle of walking into a
room full of skeptics and if you lose
that muscle that's the money making
muscle
so practice it i keep mine tight at all
times i constantly put myself
in unbilled unlisted unideal situations
when you walk onto a stage when you're
at my level which i would call myself
quite recognizable you can't say i'm
like michael mcintyre or chris rock or
someone
but i'm sort of known as a stand-up so
what that means is when i walk on stage
at the comedy store
late show 400 people drunk off their
tits work dues hindus
i'm unbilled unexpected unlisted the
room splits into three
straight away it splits into oh my god
it's him [ __ ] what a treat we've got
him for 20 quid
to the middle who's that am i supposed
to know that is is he good i don't know
i think i've seen him and the final
group
can't stand this [ __ ] that's the only
group i'm playing to win a little bit in
the middle group
they're the only people i'm interested
in because that's where the muscle
building
exercises and then when you go on stage
to your audience they get you like that
yeah yeah but if you come with that
conversion energy to your own audience
you must be
you don't need it that's the problem all
you got to do is put your foot out and
they're like it's his foot he's amazing
that's the problem yeah that's the
problem you get flabby
easy in all businesses
so you talked about your relationships
there in your current partner i um
i heard you got married for nine months
yes yeah sorry i realized what you mean
yeah no i did i was i was married bef i
was married but i'm currently
i'm trying to enjoy my middle marriage
that's what i say today
okay no i was uh so we were just we
realized we were just
mates there was a romance there we had a
lot in common we were both into this
same world
and we were sort of living together and
we got married and we were like that was
a mistake and then we just weren't
married
and it was totally amicable no no
fighting no problems at all
but you talked about the understanding
that your current
partner has current wife yeah so my
former partner
the one who was married for nine months
had that as well which is why so we
thought we should probably get married
but we realize
marriage needs more than that um so yeah
so lindsay is more
lindsay doesn't get jealous unless i do
something [ __ ] like
follow a glamour model in the instant
and like a bikini pic in which i get my
ass kicked
but still do because i'm neanderthal and
uh
um so unless i do something stupid like
that which i rightly get in trouble for
or like change my flight in ibiza and go
to a boat party which i also tried to do
and got my ass kicked for
um so but if i'm on the road
and doing autographs afterwards and
there's all girls in the picture or
something i've never ever like lindsay's
just not even a flicker she gets it
that's the job is
you're everyone's friend if the girls
fancier in the audience
even better that means another maldives
holiday type thing that's the way she's
in business mode
she isn't on a bit of an entrepreneur
lindsay she's got two businesses and
she sees my business as a business and
she
never ever guilt me i've been i might be
away for four nights
i won't some days i've gone [ __ ] i
didn't phone home i didn't text
i didn't even now and again all i have
to do is do a good night
and she knows that my head might be full
there's never any fallout
never and that just makes the trust and
the bonds it's just of course i then do
call home
it just works because of that you're
someone that will get a lot of attention
because it's i mean it's your job right
it's like holding you literally to seek
attention as much yeah
and women they love funny guys right so
god
you know probably i don't know if it's
gonna get in trouble but you know that
you could
have a lot of different partners if you
wanted to i could be harvesting 24
7. that's what i mean i probably would
have fractured pelvis by now if i hadn't
got married
people are going to hate this question
because they think i'm encouraging it
but i'm here to play devil's advocate
okay why aren't you well
um i fell deeply in love and got married
and
i'm just again you get back to the
childhood undivorced parents it's just
what i modeled on this
i've never had a problem with saying to
a girl
um the relationship's done my head's
starting to be turned let's move on
and as much as it breaks my heart if i
ever felt that way i would
obviously with a marriage in a child i
would sit down to li
to lindsay and say this an issue here
i've started to have these thoughts how
can we work on it
and we'd work something out so that's
just my way i operate
hardly any men do sorry girls for my sex
if only men did i mean
but they don't so i'm trying to a man
should go
i haven't done anything but i'm having
these thoughts what does it mean does it
mean we're not in love does it mean
sexually
our relationship's not exciting is there
something we can do that
some games we can play to mimic that i
don't know whatever couples need to just
have that conversation
because if you pretend men and women
aren't having those thoughts
you're naive so you need to keep the
relationship alive that's the way to do
to do it why why am i married well a
45 remember and b
i i'd been i'm more serial monogamist so
i've gone from age 16
to 30 odd baby the girl for three years
break up get straight with another girl
literally the next week
break up on anywhere between nine months
to three year relationships
never had a one night stand i'd never
been single
i'd never been on a lad's holiday so
when i split up a bit weird but my mum
was like you are not gonna find a
sustainable relationship because of all
these reasons you said you're gonna get
a lot of female attention
you're always gonna wonder what it's
like she went i was you i'd have a year
on your own
so i set the clock and i was like panani
master in action
and we're not cynically not cynically
shagging that's going to be the promo
clip
but not cynically shagging but being
sing
it's more to more to it than just
shagging it was like just being enough
living in a flat on your own
i bought that's banging flat in london
i've still got i use it as my london
residence and i just thought you still
got it yeah it's your wife now
well we stayed there all the time and uh
she's a and i'm like i can i
can come on live i've never lived on my
own before i'd always live with a woman
always live with a girl and uh it was
just nice i'd just be in my pajamas and
have a career and then i could i could
or i would i would just think
i'm gonna go out on the pool after the
gig and that gets boring
quick unless you've got some sort of um
issue like sex edition issue and you're
addicted to
lots of different women i'm not that
type of like dominant guy that needs to
[ __ ] a thousand women to prove i've
walked the earth
um i moy without getting too personal i
do enjoy i'm a highly sexed individual
very unfortunately for lindy incredibly
high sex drive like a 19 year old lad
but it's sex i enjoy not conquering
women so i can quench that first with
one woman over and over again but i did
want to know
what it was like to you know to be
single to be free and part of that
i'm sure it's the same for a woman for a
man is to go what's it like to have
a one night stand or to be to be a have
this rock star lifestyle and sleep with
loads of women
the difference i did it was if i was
going out after a gig or if a girl would
dm'd me and we were going out or
whatever
just missed tinder um i would say this
is where i'm at
this is what i do for a living i'm
single
i i do love making love and i love going
out but there is no relationship here i
would never
went to bed with a woman dangling any
fake carrots
ever i think it's a form of i don't want
to use
language too strongly there's a sort of
con a consent tweak in there
if you're lying if you're in a power
position like me and saying go let's see
where it goes but you just want to [ __ ]
i think that's wrong i think it's
morally wrong i think you should say
this is what it is i want to party with
you can you handle it and news flash
most women are looking for that too so i
had a wicked time for for a year and
then
one of those girls was lindsay and
that's just something different happened
and we saw
we saw each other again and again and
again and then boom married i i asked
this question because i was i was having
a conversation with a friend of mine
last night who's an entrepreneur
and he's continually failed in marriage
and we were going back and forward
about whether about the importance of
meaningful relationships and i was
making the case that they're incredibly
important i sent him a ted talk
about which shows that they did a study
on men over i think about 100 years and
showed that the men that were in
committed relationships
lived longer had way better health were
way happier they studied men for 100
years i think it's the only 100 year
study they've done of this type
and he was basically saying well you
know women that you know
they just don't understand that i'm
ambitious and stuff well is he wrong is
he right
how is he true he's statistically true
and also people that believe in god live
longer i'm not a god
i'm total atheist for you i mean that
would be the curve but you won't expect
to know right
tell me about jesus stephen there are
it's people that believe in god
live longer and so i think it's not the
case that
um faith keeps you alive or that
a relationship keeps you alive as far as
i understand the science
there's a neuro-protective and
cardiovascular benefit
of literally doing what we're doing
today just hanging out basically
and the most reliable way to hang out
and check in with someone on a really
regular basis is to have someone you're
married to are you okay
take your stress levels down or even
better get together every sunday with a
bunch of people who actually give a [ __ ]
about whether your skin whether you've
got cancer with your wife's left you
who are going to look out for you and
sadly in our society religion is the
only thing that forces people on a
friday saturday or sunday to get
together
if you're going mosque every friday is
it if you're a mosque if you're going
mosque once a week
and you're you're praying next to that
man next year he's probably going to
notice if you're down
it's as simple as that there's nothing
magic about marriage
but the homo sapiens i believe that our
cortisol
levels drop and our dopamine levels rise
when someone gives a [ __ ] about us it
would make sense on an evolutionary
level
if you look at the way chimps are that
when one of them gets excluded from the
group because they have a fight and
they're going you know you see them on
the documentary
yeah yeah they never live long because
why would you
where is the evolutionary drive of your
genes to past
seeds and eggs on if you're the type of
person who can't bring the pack forward
so there would be a strong evolutionary
argument
for single people to die before attached
to people for non-religious people
to die before atheists so atheists like
us
have to make sure we really have strong
friendship groups
and i wish wish wish we could get
humanism
off the ground every sunday there's
readings
there's your local richard dawkins is
doing a science reading we all have a
bit of tea and cake our kids all play
together
and then we all go home wouldn't that be
amazing and why doesn't it exist
it's solved a lot of problems because if
you were depressed i would pick up on it
if i'm seeing you every week
everything you've said is backed by
everything i've studied and i've read a
chapter in my book called the journey
back to human which describes this it
was
inspired a lot by johanna hari you wrote
lost connections yes
and um about getting back to our tribes
and
when you look at the way we're living
our lives today it's it's just
the antithesis of human and religion and
relationship
is the only way you can keep those human
elements in
so far as your your friends who keep
having failed marriages
marriages fail for lots of different
reasons so you
so for for men who keep getting
three-year relationships and splitting
up
if if it's the same reason every time if
the eye is roving
and he just wants to [ __ ] other women i
mean we need to speak about this in real
language that men use
sorry if you find it offensive switch
off but a lot of the time a man gets two
three years in the novel he wears off
and he's like
i just what's it going to be like a
different woman
so the cost as well the resistance or
the uncomfortable parts of the
relationship remain
yeah but the upside decreases if it's
sex a lot for a lot of men like
so i feel so sorry for girls that but
why did why did my man she what was it i
wasn't doing
it's hard to face the fact that some men
maybe 60 70
of men who split up with you just want
to shag someone else
it's let's just put on so i'm sure many
women but i don't speak for women so i'm
not being sexist
i'm just not speaking for women let get
a woman on here ask her why she splits
up with someone every three year
so you need to if you're a man that has
those urges
you need to find a woman that you can
work with that can keep you sexually
excited and do whatever you need to do
just you've got to do it and and you've
you need a woman you can talk about
those things with and a lot of it can be
role playing verb dirty talk verbal
fantasies whatever these are practical
tips a lot of couples never cross these
boundaries because they're too shy
so you split up with someone because you
wanted to get dressed up as a policeman
and potentially with someone else and
you were too cringe to tell her but that
could have been the thing that
converted it it could be as simple as as
going to a club separately dancing with
uh with other people then going home
together in the night have you tried
until you have that conversation as a
couple and admit you're having those
thoughts you will split up or worse
cheat and ruin that woman's life and
ruin her faith in men
or if you're any what i'm sure it's
exactly the same if you're a gay gay man
as well
you'll ruin that boy you've spelled if
you're in his life so far as what why
women
are with men who knows and that's not
for me to say but i do think a lot of
the times
we're reluctant to admit it's such a
basic sexual reason
i bet i i suspect it is the case and
we'll make any i just felt bored
we've grown apart you know i just wasn't
it would say any old [ __ ]
just to not admit i like looking at
girls on instagram i want to go on
holiday on my own
tough conversation to have right because
it feels like an attack on
but you build it in as fun yeah you'd be
like three years in i'm gonna be
straight with you i
really really love you as long as you
love if you don't love a girl just tell
her you
you definitely need to split up but if
you love her but i have sexual urges
that is resolvable guys i think quite
often hoochie and this is a presumption
i don't know the truth
they will take the path of least
resistance so they look over at their
partner and they think
if i have this conversation this is
going to blow up and she's going to
scream in my face
i think i can just go and grab that
apple without exactly without resistance
so they just reach out for the apple
because that conversation feels like
more psychological discomfort then yeah
i don't i just don't don't go shagging
other people to end your
your relationship we all do that they
literally cheat to end the relationship
we've all had moments i have in past
relationships where i've found myself
in a bar contemplating it talking to a
girl and as soon as that happens
i know either i don't love this girl
or something's going wrong in the
bedroom it's normally one of those
things
can you love someone and she
is the type of question you'd ask me
probably yes
yeah you think so probably in the same
in the same way i would i can adore my
daughter and would die for her but would
i go and work on a project for a month
with no phone contact at a pivotal d
vet point of her life yes i could
because i can compartmentalize
i imagine women are exactly the same i
in fact i
suspect a woman can be profoundly in
love with a man
who's not giving her attention or making
her feel special or sexually exciting
her
and she can have sex with someone else
feel awful and still profoundly love her
husband
one of the things you said is you said
you uh you're 45
46 when in august yeah yeah of course
maybe almost baby
not long you look about 31. like if you
told me you were 31 32 i'd probably
believe you
yeah um how have you done that so first
of all
it's got me into trouble um because what
happened was when i started doing all
this biohacking and stuff like that
what's biohacking
it's where your work you're using the
current science
available to try and hack your own
biology to
survive on less sleep in a way that
doesn't damage your health for example
i've not cracked that one
to not lose your hair working on that
one
or to slow down the aging process
so not so that you can live to 120 not
that
it's a common misconception but that so
you can have the bit of your life
between 30 and 70 in a more sustained
younger state that's what you're trying
to do
you're trying to have better middle-aged
years
not be 120 year old what you'd like to
be is 120 year old that's like an 80
year old now
what you're trying to do is stretch
particularly i did my first gig at 28
so i quickly realized i need to find
some solutions here because i'm high
energy lee evans act
i talk about my mum my dad i'm a late
bloomer i've got what i'm gonna
i would end up having a wife much
younger than me i need to have
the body of a 30 year old man quick so i
started
studying i mean i was 30 at the time you
know what i mean i need to keep it here
um so the trouble it got me into is when
stuff started to work dramatically work
i would sit down in interviews like this
with journalists and people will go how
old are you russell when i was they were
guests trying to get a compliment and
they would
they started to guess four years younger
five years younger than 10 years younger
than 15 years younger like you have
today
and i thought this is showbiz [ __ ] that
i'm gonna knock a few years off
because the one prejudice people are
still allowed to have not book you cause
you're old can't wait till
old life matters starts because i'm
going to be [ __ ] behind no but
seriously
why can we why is it okay to make
redundant and underpay and exclude
people
based on their chronological age
but that prejudice alive and well um so
i i thought i lied i lied my ass off and
of course i was really unsophisticated
about it i was like celebrating my real
birthday with comedians and friends
and then lying to the observer or the
mirror how much did you lie by five
years oh not bad
i forgive you um but so that was a story
that was a tabloid story
in two newspapers and i and a lot of
jokes were made on tv
a comedy awards ceremony so i was quite
mocked for it so as a comedian
eminem style i took that wrote a show
about it called right man wrong age
took it on tour owned it no one said a
word since and now i talk about it all
the time i think it's quite funny really
it's quite human i mean what the [ __ ] if
so if i don't know what whatever the
thing is in your profession maybe
it's age as well it's been aged for me
when i was 18 everyone wrote about me
because i would like
i'd made a hundred pounds when i was 18
and i realized that in my industry
your age and the achievement are the
most important things so when if i was
18 i've made a hundred quid
they had me on bbc this 18 year old's
made a hundred quid right and i realized
that by
when i get to 25 i actually need to have
made about 100 million for them to
consider me the same way yeah
so i'm like super slowly changing my
birthday every year i'm like oh 27. i'm
like i need to be a billionaire
right so but from a business sense it
might be exaggerating turnover to seek
investment then revealing real turnover
afterwards but say okay we were winning
this anyway that type thing so i was
exaggerating
turnover to attract investment um
but i didn't realize it was a massive
issue because people come to stand up
comedians for authenticity and realness
particularly my type of stand-up so
anyway i
owned that chucked it back that's all
good
how i've done it is just there's loads
of places you can go to
i started with dave asprey and
bulletproof and all of those things
although i do think drinking butter is
way over the top
but it's moving towards a lower
carb not keto nothing extreme i don't
believe in anything extreme that's hard
to stick to but certainly i don't
believe we're supposed to eat
white bread and cereal and [ __ ] like
that working with what we build to do
would be the most basic way without
spending money anyone that's watching
this can start
we woke up on the savannah this morning
you and i it's time to go hunting
there ain't going to be food there we
probably would have eaten at 2 p.m
no doubt about it human beings are built
to have
anywhere between 16 hour to 2 day
fasting gaps
no doubt about it
and sure enough now we look at this on a
cellular level we can see what happens
so i ate at um last night i went very
late so i didn't eat till nearly 11 p.m
by now as i'm speaking to you not only
do i have an intense [ __ ] focused
high
from only having had coffee and water
which has got to be a good thing
there's um autophagy going on in my
cells
so the cells are eating up their own
bits of dead
protein and [ __ ] just out of sheer
desperation for something to eat
that's the first thing that happens
apoptosis is the proper name for it
the cells that the [ __ ] ones just die
and burn off
like the crust at the edge if you pour
food on the edge of that situation as
far as i understand the science i'm sure
people will
refine what i'm saying i'm trying to
distill what i've learned for the layman
you you keep all that crap in so
unfortunately we're pro
fasting is brilliant i don't buy into
many fads but the science here you can
see under a microscope
so intermittent fasting and eating lower
carb is something anyone can do someone
on 10 grand a year can do that tomorrow
so eat more like leafy green vegetables
i think if you're on 10 grand
you are probably into yeah exactly but
eat more leafy green vegetables
breakfast is
i think the easiest one to skip because
you produce a hormone in the night that
suppresses appetite anyway otherwise
you'd wake up hungry all night
if you are waking up hungry or diets
[ __ ] change it so you don't i
won't wake up hungry so we're brought up
to wake up not hungry and eat a bowl of
cocoa pops and then boom the insulin
goes up
insulins you don't want your insulin
high and the only way to do that is
sugar and carbohydrate
so lower your carbohydrate 120 gram net
a day anyone can do that still rice if
you like bread eat bread but eat
wholemeal bread
that's the two most basic things you can
do
now so far as the more intense
chemicals i can tell you what i'm on i
would take phytation in the morning
which is a synalytic activator
something that's that stops cell
um decrease and senescence like aging in
cells
once a week i will probably also take
another synalytic activator
a chloroquine is called i take pqq every
morning that's the little pink one
i do take nmn which is really expensive
but
the the life force in the cells that
keep us going is called nats nad
and that's what causes aging aging is
not inevitable
it's your cells we're a combination of
digital and analog information so every
time you rewrite a cell it gets
rewritten a little bit less well and
then you get wrinkles and gray hair and
you start forgetting and you die
so if you can help the cells be more
accurate in writing
you can stay younger not just in how you
look but generally
so i do take nmn every day that's the
big one
and that that is a precursor to creating
nad
in the body and i've i mean i have no
botox i have no filler
in my face i do use stuff from boots and
moisturizer and i do go for like a posh
facial now and again
but there's nothing artificial in my
skin um
this is a great point moment to cut to
my podcast sponsor nmn
loads of people make it okay um if
you're looking for a good one
in the uk go on amazon i think it's
double wood he's good
it's expensive though man you're looking
at six pounds a day
for a substantive yeah five six pounds a
day but if you think if you're spending
if you're lucky enough to be spending
that on on a coffee take a flask
buy an mn instead i bought my own coffee
today
so what i will do is my pet hate is
watching
a video like this listen to podcasters
and people not listing
grams and brands afterwards and all the
top guys
david sinclair's the guy you want to
read by the way if you read one book it
will change your life it's
why we age and why we don't have to
david sinclair he does all the science
but he always refuses
to give like geeky levels of endorsement
what i take because his
inbox always crashes so what i will do
is i will
i will send you exactly what i take on a
daily basis
you need to check with your physician
and you need to make sure everything's
right for you
obviously but nmn is definitely the one
that
encourages nad production and helps the
cells copy themselves and slow down
aging
resveratrol very very very important so
i take a
um 750 milligrams of nmm and i take a
gram of resveratrol every morning
don't go on amazon and buy resveratrol
the brown stuff you need
trans resveratrol the ultra refined
stuff
you need a gram of it a day vita fair is
is a good brand
what about hair hair they've still not
starting to get grazed
yeah they're still not solved why we go
gray or
because baldness is a genetic program
that's running
like your height it's harder to hack
it's to do with the testosterone hormone
dhd that kicks in
dht that kicks in um so your body
after a while and the way it synthesizes
testosterone in the scalp
causes the follicles to die and fall off
the only way to do that is to block
dht but if you're a man it's a too
it's a double-edged sword because if you
start messing with your testosterone you
can lower your sex drive
lower your aggression i need lots of
aggression in what i do when i go on
stage and for exercise and things
so i don't take things like um
finisteride which we know works
because i'd rather be jason statham
like bald and horny than have loads of
hair in a eunuch
that said um i am losing my hair at the
crown i have been for about two years
the reason you can't see it today as
much as you could two years ago i am
using a derma roller
um you can buy these cheaply on amazon
make sure you buy
one with individual titanium spikes if
it's boasting
hundreds of titanium spikes it's a shite
one it means they've got a rolled out
bit of titanium
you want one if it's plastic it'll be
about 190 200 spikes
titanium and you'll be able to see each
individual spike 0.5 millimeter
once a day roll roll roll it's a little
bit painful roll roll and roll
at the temples here and then you would
put on
minoxidil 15 ideally duoden's a good one
again very expensive you're looking at
340 quid a month
um but it works what does it do you
start to get first of all little pubi
gray hairs and it just holds the wolf
so you're not bald you don't have like
17 year old hair
but as you can see i am no i am not bald
and that's all i do the roller is the
roll is about
oh no the roll is about a tenner
the minoxidil is expensive but you can
get like a get it down to about 30
pounds a month but don't go below 15
and if you really want to do belt on
braces how you shampoo is important get
a really good
caffeine shampoo like alpacin and you
want um
a brush like it's like a round
really cheap round plastic brush with
the plastic bristles like boys would
have gelled their hair with back in the
day
one of those and when the shower really
scrubbed that shampoo in
and leave it for five minutes so if you
shave or you brush your teeth don't have
your toothbrush and shave while the
foam's there
and then shower it out how did you get
into all of this was it that book
no no that's i've just researched myself
the optimal methods for hair regrowth
but for biohacking
i've used david perlmutter the doctor a
cardiovascular doctor about heart health
and
cholesterol and make trying to learn the
safety of going higher fat
i use dave asprey for a lot of the
supplements your pqq
and things like that and all the
knowledge about high fat and biohacking
and sleep and all that
and i use david sinclair for the real
real
hardcore science on life extension
it's a brilliant book it's just about
accessible for the main reader but if
you get into it you love it there's
loads of stuff in there i don't do like
the cold showers and things like that
cold showers tell me about that i've uh
i've heard about this but i just don't
have the guts
every day it just feels like it will
ruin my day the most controversial thing
about what i've said
is i'm not recommending people go low
carb i'm just saying it's what i do
you might come from australasia
and you might have different genetics
that mean you if you eat a high fat diet
it's incredibly dangerous
check what your doctor recommends go and
do your own research
go to atlas biomed where you can get
your own biome sequence by sending a bit
of poo through the post it's fascinating
and they send back your whole internal
microbiome
get your cholesterol tested three months
in six months in
see what it's doing my cholesterol of
course is off the [ __ ] charts
but so is my hdl cholesterol meaning my
cholesterol ratio is good
do i have plaques in my arteries
yes i do i've run a ct scan
so you need to take your own call on
that
i mean if you're a student and you get
hit by a car and you're 18 years old and
we do an autopsy
you will have plaque in your arteries
babies have plaque in their arteries we
all have blackener arteries
i remain to be convinced that the fact i
have cholesterol running around my blood
actually is the thing that makes the
plaque cholesterol
that i'm in a minority i'm not medically
trained
i could be talking [ __ ] and i could be
in the coffin when i'm 60.
but i'm fascinated by it i'm a layman
i'm on a journey
you do your own reading the nhs
recommendation certainly isn't
eat high fat but i just don't buy the
science
it stinks to me so and plus i just
i'm going on how i feel sure yeah
probably the most important way
um your podcast you have a podcast which
um
talks a lot about cancer culture yes
what's um what's going on our society at
the moment in terms of cancer culture it
seems to be getting much more
uh maybe because of algorithms and we're
we're separate you know we're creating
these echo chambers and we're defining
you know this side is you know left and
this is right and there's nothing in the
middle but what's going on within
society and uh
i guess the question i'm going to come
to eventually is how how do we fix it
and can we fix it mm-hmm where are we
[ __ ]
i think we're probably a little bit
[ __ ] for the time being because
after loads of historic injustice and
inequality and
i hate the word woke i don't i almost
don't want to be woke because it's such
a [ __ ] word
um i just think waking up to things
you've not seen before
the word wokes become politicized so i
reject it as a term
but we we need to swing the barometer a
little bit this way
until everyone's being represented
properly then it will settle probably in
our children's generation it will settle
to stop
panicking gary davely and everyone with
a union jack profile
it will it will settle um
what i find frustrating and toxic
is we're living in a culture where you
can be canceled overnight
at middleton cancelled overnight sharon
i was born cancelled overnight
it doesn't matter who you are what your
background is what color or gender you
are you are at risk
no one is safe trust me especially white
men
well anyone really i remember um i don't
even know if i want to put it back out
there but
no reggie eights of it and he said
something about jewish music producers
yeah i remember
just about survived that so i i i don't
think anyone i think any
in fact i think it's probably worse if
you're of color because the right will
be ready they'll be [ __ ] receive
[ __ ] c so i would actually say no i
would say
i think everyone's at risk from this
it's a rabid
oh we got one of them particularly a
lefty and cancelled him
how can we live in a culture of instant
black tradition say black and white
after what is there but instant black
and white cancelling
where you can wake up in the morning and
be gone that at the same time
exists alongside how dare you use a
label nothing has meaning
we're in a post-modern world of
amorphous fog where we don't even have
pronouns
nothing's real history is not real the
things you've learned aren't real
literature isn't literature
nothing has a label no you're cancelled
and i'm sure what
yeah well which is it oh are we in a
post-modern nothing means anything
everything's up for grabs shifting
meaning
diverse culture which sounds quite
exciting to me as a comedian
or are we in a nazi germany executed the
next morning
both of those two together head [ __ ]
i have this tweet saved in my drafts on
twitter and it says and i didn't tweet
it because i didn't have the nuts right
because i was being i was like loki
being canceled for something i said at
the time so i thought i'll just
stagger this one out but it says the
left will allow you to be non-binary in
everything but your opinion
right and it's kind of what you're
saying there it's like we've got to the
point where we understand things aren't
binary
right in sexuality and other points but
my opinion has to be
like if the stance i take on black lives
matter doesn't perfectly
i don't look like i'm wearing like as i
said in the last podcast with anne
the football kit shoes socks shirt
then i am definitely of the right and i
should be treated as such yeah
and i i had it quite recently with the
um dia sarah everett
every tragedy because i made the point
that the narrative and this is this key
sentence that i just
social media just didn't allow me to
express then which
narrative is most helpful
and productive in creating the shift we
need to see
in male behavior which narrative is it
the narrative
that um which i saw a lot of which is
it's it
all men all men are the are the the
problem
is that the narrative which is most
helpful and productive
and so the the conversation i was trying
to have is real politic what works in
the real world yeah i'm not saying
there's not a [ __ ] problem with men
or they're not pigs or there's not like
the patriarchy or there's not misogyny
the stats say that i'm not the stats the
stats say 97
of young women have experienced some
form of sexual abuse or harassment
my my point is about that which
narrative is most productive
and helpful you're a businessman you're
like which model can we employ to get
the best profit yeah because i i reflect
i said well when tommy
when tommy robertson ran around saying
okay it's not all muslims
but it's always muslims that are blowing
up buildings whatever we would run them
out of town because that's a deeply
toxic
way to think right and it's the same
with black people like we get you know
locked up more
so asserting that you know it's not all
black people but
it's some black people therefore the
fear is all black people the way that i
got to my logic i was like
i have two nieces who are gonna go into
the world who i love dearly
what would i say to them they're four
years old and three years old
what advice would i say to them to help
them a
guard against predatory male behavior
but also to help them in their life be
productive and to work with 50 percent
of the population it definitely wouldn't
be
lse right sit down you're gonna have to
fear all men
some of them the threat alessi is my
niece is
all men that's not for me wouldn't be a
imagine the damage i would do to
my niece i mean i don't know what to say
you
put it brilliantly i i i got finished
off i got finished so badly
on instagram i was [ __ ] are they
finished me it's because
part of the problem is having a
discussion like this when a girl has
just died
if you and i to have this at university
in two years time
it's quite an interesting it's a very
interesting conversation that needs to
be had
so i did do a stand-up response to it i
did a one-minute thing but i waited 10
days
smart i waited 10 days and then i did a
rant about
um why do we teach sex education so late
why do we teach consent so late and
i just made fun of the british education
system not speaking to teenagers about
sex enough because i think that's what
the issue is
um we don't teach our but at all boys
whether they're whether they're
predatory boys or not
men aren't all about sex early enough
from angels
to sex offenders they should be taught
in primary school not from porn
no exactly that's where the problem is
um but yeah
so i think sometimes having trying to
have a con i i do actually just disagree
slightly with one thing she said
right at the top which was when you said
oh um
i need to have a binary opinion but but
not have
a binary sexuality because i i do think
no you can have a non-binary opinion i
we could be talking about jane austen
and literature and we can say
yeah but i can't think of a subject you
and i can can have a conversation on
where fashionable post-modernism nothing
means anything doesn't apply
on a major issue black lives matter yeah
we could we could we could talk
we could talk about now we're not we're
not going to say whether black lives
matter or not
but we could have a discussion about
rape does race exist on a genetic level
we prove that it doesn't so what is race
does
we could we could chat and everyone
could leave the electoral going i don't
know what to think
in a lecture or face to face or we could
broadcast it now
talk talk about race 100 talk about does
race exist and this is why i love
podcasts because you get context and
nuance
180 characters in the middle of the
black lives matter
russell why haven't you posted the black
tile you can't go well does racing exist
people go racist
silence is violence but you can still
but what i mean is we can be post-modern
fluffy and not say anything almost about
anything
but we still be canceled at the same
time now those two things are both quite
extreme yeah
i mean they're opposites and that's
making class cloak can close down debate
and
hamstrung people i like my
um offensive people
where i can hear them i don't like them
on whatsapp groups hidden
i was never against um nick griffin of
the bnp going on question time i don't
mind putting that out there
a lot of people say you put him on there
you legitimize his views what actually
happened
he looked like a total [ __ ] and now he's
disappeared
have the courage to know like i do think
there is good and bad
i don't think right-wing people are bad
left-wing people are good in fact i
think it's just as many [ __ ] across the
spectrum
i do think violence and hatred is bad
full stop sorry i do
it's a moral absolute moral category i
would rather see the people who think it
have their arguments exposed the biggest
experiment we've ever seen of that is
donald trump yeah
where his [ __ ] just fell apart
because most people saw he was a [ __ ]
regardless of what he'll tell you
and then you probably won't see someone
like him for a long while now
he was right and that sort of right-wing
sentiment rose around the world at the
same time like bolsonaro
yeah even here in europe all at the same
time and it almost feels like now it's
falling
a little bit away i don't like chastity
belts and and gagging and things and
that
the when they were like donald trump's
coming we won't give him a state visit
nonsense i want
red carpet i want streets lined and let
him hear
what we think let him see the way
british people show they're unhappy
don't sort of all mutter into your tea
poses and send memes
like in shoreditch [ __ ] let's go out
there let's let's
let's let's where's our pranksters
where's simon brodkin doing a stunt on
him
that you know have the courage of your
of your arguments
the goodies always winning films and
they will win on the earth i believe
that i'm an optimist
should anybody be cancelled d platformed
chucked off immediately thrown out
not in haste that's why i make evil
genius
it's a slow weighing up over the hour
we take the good and the bad we have an
intellectual discussion and it's very
tongue-in-cheek and funny
but it's a long discussion about the
people's merits
it's interesting as well the elitism of
it as well why are picasso's paintings
still hanging
why the guy was a grade a nonce and
misogynist
why are his painting still up because
it's so lofty and important we can't
quite bring ourselves to cancel it
i mean i don't know if do we go here i
mean i don't know what i think of that
michael jackson documentary anyway
but it's almost like michael jackson's
so powerful and musically important
that we dare not go there so there comes
to a stage where
we're not willing you know someone sort
of cancel proof
i mean if you're really really
controversial look at the old testament
he did some vile [ __ ] things stoning
people
like flooding people with fire
burning gaze how has he not been
cancelled old school god
too powerful that's interesting i've
never actually considered that some
people are too michael jackson's a very
good example because
i don't want to give it my spotify is
going to be empty i might just go over
bump and grind being deleted
all right do you know it's funny because
i was actually thinking about michael
jackson this week because i just
absolutely adore the art
yeah and have it the thought of having
to separate
mike the the artist from the art and
that the artist could have been
such a horrible predator it re
something that helped you know the
useful rule of thumb i've found is
the closer the art is to the predation
and the nature of the predation the more
problematic it is so i find picasso very
problematic because everything i'm
looking at in the studio is
in a gallery it's possibly a teenage
girl's body
i find michael jackson problematic
because when he's talking about love and
i want to be close to you and i want to
touch this and that what's he singing
about
what am i dancing to yeah if someone
writes beautiful romantic novels
but they like harming animals in private
less problematic
because when i'm reading the novel i'm
not absorbing animal harm sure am i
absorbing pedophilia if the song is
who's r kelly singing about bumble grind
with whom an underage do you see what i
mean yeah
so what's what's next for you what are
you working on what's um what's the next
chapter of your life all about and as
far as you're
concerned well uh as well as just doing
tv all the time
whoring it up on any show that will have
me which i've been doing since i started
it's about the theater's reopening um
for now
outdoor social distance performance so
i'll be finding as many spaces where i
can put a marquee over vented at the
side
just to get back out there and stay
sharp i am working on a novel i always
um
i'm working on a sitcom i always am and
i'm developing formats i always am i'm
always hustling
always trying i'm yet to get that format
away where i own it and it's my ip
i have with evil genius i have i have
made a tv pilot of that with bbc studios
i would love to sell that because i
think that would work globally as a
format
very timely as well i have got my eye on
things like that as well but mostly it's
how can i get in front of people and
make them laugh because that's what i
want to do
well uh you certainly are very good at
that um
it's it's a talent that you have that
i'm like positively jealous of like just
your natural ability to make people
feel comfortable and to laugh it's a
real i feel the same with you
multi-million pound businesses
i wish i had that i feel like i would
have been more successful if i had that
i told you for one year
we both keep revenue no no no
thank you for coming today no thank you
so much it's been a real pleasure and i
don't think people realize how much of a
[ __ ] intellectual you are
my first clue was all those books you
had behind you in your zoom background
when i did your
podcast but i dug my way out the ghetto
with books like that
you're so [ __ ] smart and i don't
think people realize that i think they
think you're a comedian you're much more
than a comedian you're
[ __ ] genius at the same time it
doesn't pay to look too smart when
you're a comic
true i'm ready to i love radio 4 but i
want to be on itv one as well i
disrespect us
listen thank you so much for your time
today and um people people know where
they can find you but your podcast evil
genius is immense
and it's very timely and needed in our
society so thank you for doing that and
i am
trying to squeeze out stand up on
channel four during the day so if you're
ever
at home or you've got a day off steph's
packed lunch twice a week i'm on there
doing that i never thought i'd do dates
i'm telling you i [ __ ] i love it and
i do stand up at 1pm
world needs that too right now yeah
thank you so much russell appreciate it
thank you
[Music]
[Music]